so I know you guys said right now you
wouldn't
um you'd rather live with roommates than
a man right that's not what I'm saying
about myself
is the way that you phrased the question
you were asking us like how like where
would we have to be in our lives to be
an Alliant on a man in his income and I
think phrasing it that way like okay
okay fine fine but like when there's a
recession if you had to make a choice
right if if your income was getting slim
you would pick family over a man yeah
right
I have the option to do that so yeah if
I was in a relationship that's different
but I have the option okay so so let's
say like you lose your job tomorrow and
you have to think I either have to move
home or I have to get into a
relationship right right right now right
now right now right right now you would
pick moving home or moving in with a
roommate that's that's what you guys
said earlier I would suggest that to be
fair if you had no income coming in
moving in with a guy you don't really
know what his real Financial
circumstances and you might become a bit
of a burden and that might actually
crash the relationship yeah yeah
I'm not I'm not I'm I'm just asking yeah
home for us I'm not responding to this
question
my question is would that change if you
were older if I was older like if this
happened at 32 33 34 35 would you ever
start prioritizing relationships over
um like moving home home or moving on
with roommates me personally no I like I
don't view really or I don't even get
into relationships where
um money is a main proponent of that
like I I it's nice if we can go out on
like dates and we go out to eat and
we're going we're having a great time
and things like that but I'm also fine
with like picnics in the car when it's
just cheese and crackers like you know
like like it doesn't always have to be
well I'm not even talking about dates I
was talking about rent yeah
I understand like you're right like
you're in a situation your rent needs to
cut in half you either find a man or you
go home right exactly I'm just trying to
put it together like there's just no
situation where
it like even when I'm making money where
I'm going to be financially reliant on
the man I'm definitely not going to do
it when I'm when I'm not late I I
personally I would go with my family do
you want kids no oh you don't want kids
okay well then fair enough then you
don't need it yeah yeah I mean it I feel
like because even you asked earlier like
how how do I feel about being 60 years
old do I have a man or do I have a
roommate I mean being 60 and having a
roommate we're just out here you know
pushing little kids hitting people with
our canes like that sounds like a good
time like
a child abuse
I'm just curious have you always felt
like that
um you know different relationships have
shown me different things so I have been
in relationships with men where I was
like okay I could have children with you
I can see us moving in that direction
they can see us getting married I can
see us owning the house I can see his
reproducing and and like creating a
legacy that way
um but I it's not in every relationship
and even now that I'm single like I'm
definitely not pursuing that okay but
for it sounds like for the right guy you
still would yeah yeah yeah would you say
like your intentions changed before you
met someone so like did you think oh I'd
never want to have kids before I met
someone and then you got in a
relationship and you're like actually
maybe I would change my mindset or was
it always I'll never have kids in a
relationship with one of our kids and it
got to like a certain point and you're
like actually but it so it was more so
like
I I don't know I don't know how to get
into this without saying like I I have
both of our families are pretty large
right all together there's 10
grandchildren right and so we grew up in
a yeah like yeah Summer's at Grandma's
house were always super fun and
um seeing sort of like the effect that
our parents had on us and like on our
other cousins and things like that it
was just kind of like I don't want to
have that effect on people
um and so when I got into a relationship
and I was like oh if we got together and
we were taking care of kids we wouldn't
have that effect on people we could
actually
builds like a very like beautiful
prosperous like family like I was like
okay okay I can see myself doing that
but otherwise it's just kind of like I I
can see us recreating like you were
saying before generational trauma like I
can see us recreating that generational
trauma and that's not something I wanted
that's a negative way to look alive yeah
you're looking at the worst case
scenario but did you say um yeah did you
say your life is not full of rainbows
and sunshines like it's not gonna be
like all good all the time I know bad
all the time you're gonna have to have a
balance of both yeah so to just look at
the wrong that's happened to you
but did you say you were from a family
that like I'm not sure if you said your
parents were still together my parents
were still together my parents are
divorced yeah okay and there's so my my
mom is her brother
yeah so yeah but there's only two of
them so two people made ten
grandchildren yeah no that's a problem
surprise me yeah obviously because
obviously it was the whole what you said
I would would have expected it to be the
opposite obviously where you said that
you come from um your parents are still
together I would have expected the
opposite where you would have said um
you would you would want children
because obviously from what your parents
you've got two large families and when
it's come to like comes to festive
events you're all together that's what I
was surprised when you said that's why I
asked the question yeah like I'm the one
who wants yeah and it's funny to see
like obviously generation like true
everyone experiences yeah yeah I I I I
hear this question I've heard it on your
podcast before
um but nobody's ever like mentioned the
fact that the process of having kids is
like having kids raising children yeah
the best of your ability you know
without obviously going too far afield
and [ __ ] it all up I'm scared and
then you get old and your children look
after you like what happens when you get
old with no kids who's gonna look after
you and I think this brings up a good
point that we were making before you
mentioned community and you were talking
about how you would like your partner to
help you build your community with you
and I assume like your you and your
partner have kids and that creates your
community me personally like I I build
my community with like my church when
I'm going out to friends I go to like a
chess club like uh even like my work
friends and things like that like those
people are my my main community and I'm
not necessarily expecting them to
um like be by my bedside feeding me
porridge when I'm you know I can't they
might come through I'm sorry yeah
I have a question I have a question you
said so your church Community that's
where you'd find like that sense of
community when you're old interesting
um currently right now I'm still like
looking for churches that align with how
I personally experience Christianity but
yes like I'm looking for a church that
would allow me to do that that would
allow me to like rely on people work
with people if I needed food and I'm 60
and I or I mean
do you think that's realistic to expect
a church to take care of you when you're
old this is what I'm saying I'm looking
for the right church and I'm looking for
the right Community like I'm still I
don't necessarily have my
decrepit 80 year old Community yet
[Laughter]
she has a sizable family like I will
have children my brother will yeah
are you honestly going to be like sorry
but are you honestly going to be as
happy as you think that let's say you're
60 or 75 do you honestly believe you're
going to be as happy like let's say for
example you have children and those
children that let's say you're 75 years
old you know let's say for example your
husband ain't there but you have your
children who are going to look after you
they're going to come and if you need
some shopping they're going to come and
shop for you and all of that [ __ ] do you
honestly think you don't want that at 75
because like let me let me keep it real
they might even at 75 man them out there
you know the manam you're looking at
right now they're not going to look at
you when you're 75. I'm sorry they're
gonna stop looking at you when you're
50. maybe even 40 right push it at 35
you feel me I'm sorry
do you understand they believe that keep
in mind from like 30 is that someone's
phone sorry this phone was going off so
I'm going a bit of a rant but like do
you honestly Whoever has found that is
step off camera and turn it off we said
to turn the phones off before the show
but go ahead I don't know who's found
that sounds like a weird Mario game yeah
yeah mad takes honestly
yeah
okay I don't I don't know whose it was
do you honestly believe that after the
age of 35 like keep in mind women in
general they look for a certain type of
man you'll fool me like if a man who's
five foot two looks like a bowling ball
you know it's like it's smelly and all
of that if he walks up to you you're not
going to give him the time of day you
feel me so you want a certain type of
man okay right and whatever your
standards are understand that certain
type of man he's gonna look for a
certain type of woman
and I'm so sorry to tell you this and I
hope I don't get canceled for this but
usually women over 35 they ain't the
type of man they're looking for uh sorry
they're not the type of woman they're
looking for you feel me so do you
honestly believe when you get parts
sorry holiday I'm 26 26. you've lived 26
years of your life already you feel me
do you honestly and do you know how long
26 years are you know because you've
lived 26 years you feel me when you get
to that 50 you're going to live up to
that 75 80. do you honestly believe that
time by yourself is going to be an
enjoyable time
um so yeah so I'm going to bring up a
couple of points that you mentioned so
first things first like I don't want to
bring kids into this world with the
intention of having somebody to take
care of me okay so
is that I happen to live in one of the
greatest generations to ever exists
where if for whatever reason I didn't
have children and I wasn't able to leave
my bed I can just take out my phone in
Amazon whatever I need
it
from Amazon
stop everyone you can't go out at the
same time don't you don't you think
that's Lonely no no you guys really lack
Community like and I'm not saying like
you specifically I'm saying like I I'm
able to find so much satisfaction and
joy and peace and goodness and and
fulfillment in in my friends and and my
other relations I think that's easy as a
young woman I think the point he's
making is the world treats you different
after like 45 or 50.
yeah so as a young woman like you're
treated better by the world and so
because you're young you're attractive
you're pretty and so and so it's like
you're gonna hit 45.50 the world's gonna
look at you different you start to be
treated like a man no I'm serious
there's I'm already bald I'm halfway
there the momentum stop buying you
drinks you you're going to see the world
differently you're going to the club
right now and man was like oh can I buy
you a drink oh you're so beautiful and
all that kind of stuff listen the moment
you hit 35 that's gonna stop my friends
stop him
like what is this man saying I love the
I'm speaking reality what
I love the the concept of what's it
what's your issue with what he's saying
everything okay he's first of all he's
being so heteronormative like like these
are a lot of assumptions that he's
making right now what is what is
heterono I don't know heteronormative is
just making making an assumption that
someone is heterosexual first of all so
as this entire line this whole monologue
he's doing is assuming that she's only
interested in men and that she's only
interested in what a man wants or what a
man could see in her I mean I think
that's not that's like that's that's
just not what life is like I I mean I'm
not gonna like not just you're just
making a lot of some assumptions and
running down the street with them and I
understand the logic behind where he's
coming from like I'm not saying that
he's being like he's being illogical but
because he's basing all of his from my
perspective a lot of where your sounding
board of information is
is your foundation is heteronormativity
massaging me and the fact that like and
it's just not it's just not an alignment
but okay wait it's just not in alignment
with where I where I find my foundation
so I'm like pushing back on the opinions
that he has so heteronormative I I still
think it would be sad if you were a
single lesbian woman so like I think
it's like a personal like we're also
like making assumptions that she's
single she didn't say that she just said
that she doesn't want to have children
or yeah well fair enough but like this
like whole conversation was under the
perspective of whether or not she would
be happy without having children and
then the second the second yeah I mean
it's a it's a valid question I think
yeah your answer could be I would be
perfectly happy but I just said over and
over and over again and he's trying to
like break down why she's wrong and all
these policies
points that maybe she didn't think about
and maybe she has and maybe like but I
think that's what we're supposed to do
on a podcast
and I'm exploring the idea that
so so what do you what do you think what
is that he said misogynistic I think
that like making this the assumption
that like her the prospects of her life
her future happiness is based upon
whether or not a man objectively a man
would find her attractive after the age
of like what 35 that he said for me is
like
is like is misogynist oh I think that's
true I don't this I well I think that's
your opinion yeah I mean I think it's
true I think most women aren't happy
that are that are single childless over
the age of like 45 they're the least
happy demographic that's interesting
that's interesting I just I just could
not get behind that I was asking if you
have statistics on that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible